es ist fünf nach zwölf das sagt der chef
des robert koch-instituts gerade und er
meint damit nicht die uhrzeit er meint
die korona lage hier in deutschland aber
ist die korona lage wirklich so
dramatisch so dass alles zu spät ist das
meint ja fünf nach zwölf es gibt so
viele corona fragen so viel unsicherheit
wieder ungewissheit und bei uns im
studio deshalb jetzt der top wie roll
over hendrik strikt bei bild live und
sie zu hause haben die möglichkeit uns
zu fragen nein ihn zu fragen herzlich
willkommen und alle antwortet
hoffentlich gerne was glauben sie ja
schräg was ist im moment das was die
deutschen in dieser corona situation am
meisten umtreibt was wird die
meistgestellte frage aktuell seien also
die frage die mir am meisten gestellt
wird ist ob man sich postern lassen soll
oder nicht weil auf der einen seite hat
die stiko empfehlung da ist und auf der
anderen seite der
bundesgesundheitsminister gesagt hat
jeder kann sich postern lassen die frage
ist die medizinisch sinnvoll es ist und
da bin ich sehr bei der stiko dass man
sagt man soll jetzt mal wirklich denen
den vortrag wir lassen die die gefahr
haben für einen schweren verlauf und
potenziell die impfung nachgelassen hat
also ältere generale gruppen
risikopatienten usw und dass man dann
anfängt meine alter stratifizierung und
risikostrategie zierung und dann
vielleicht auch später dann über eine
besserung für andere nachdenkt aber der
effekt ist in dem sinne noch nicht
wirklich evident dass das auch bei
jüngeren einen einfluss hat da ist ja
die cdc empfehlung oder die empfehlungen
in england relativ ähnlich wie die stiko
und nochmal abhängig vom impfstoff das
ist ja eine erfahrung die wir diese
woche gemacht haben mit unserem großen
bild antikörpertest diejenigen die
astrazeneca geimpft bekommen haben
relativ früh im jahr die waren dann
nicht mehr ganz so fein in dieser
antikörper tabelle die wir hier
aufgestellt haben da war es nicht
dramatisch aber die standen eben nicht
mehr so gut da wie die kollegen und
kolleginnen die biotech oder moderner
bekommen hatten ja auch immer eine
chance nun ja auch da waren die
antikörper eher im unteren bereich ja
und aber johnson & johnson auch
astrazeneca soweit ich weiß es sehr
interessant die weil während biontech
und moderne einen schnelleren abfall
haben in den antikörper leveln ist bei
johnson zenica der wert niedriger von
anfang an aber die haben nicht ganz so
schnellen abfall unter bei einigen kreuz
sich da schon die der graf also dass
dann am ende vielleicht die beiden
vector impfstoffe doch höhere antikörper
im langen verlauf haben also mussten
keine booster panik würden sie alle
machen unter den jüngeren leuten während
die älteren auch jetzt langsam boostern
sollten aber keine booster panik nein
das einzige was wichtig ist jemand der
johnson & johnson gekriegt hat der
sollte booster bekommen eine dritte
impfung ist vor allem für die bullen
arabien gruppen entscheidend die anderen
kommen dann noch warten wir haben es
versprochen nicht nur wir dürfen hier
unsere fragen an sie stellen sondern
auch unsere zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
sie beschäftigt nämlich derzeit ganz
viel zum thema corona wie sieht's mit
weihnachten auskommen ja ich will gar
nicht sagen das böse an bord wie schon
die nächsten wochen aus wir fangen jetzt
mal an uns wurden wie das eingeschickt
frau will er aus saarbrücken hat eine
dringende frage es geht um das thema in
pflicht guten tag herr professor ist
fähig bin die frau wille aus saarbrücken
gestellte mal eine frage an sie wäre die
pandemie nicht schneller vorbei wenn wir
eine impf ließ treten ja also das finde
ich eine sehr interessante debatte die
man da führen kann mit der empfiehlt die
frage ist nur wie man das einmal
umsetzen will man kann ja ich glaube
auch bundesgesundheitsminister ersparen
hat das ja in der pk heute gesagt dass
man ja nicht von tür zu tür ziehen kann
und die leute vor die nadel ziehen kann
auf der anderen seite sehe ich es aber
auch als schwierig an beim ist es ein
impfstoff den wir zwar viel erfahrung
mittlerweile mit haben aber nicht sagen
können wie lange ist denn der impfschutz
die häufig brauchen wir einen booster
kann jeder wirklich moderne bekommen
oder doch braucht dann doch eher bei
montech und da hat ja auch die stiko
gerade eine revidiert in den
empfehlungen und einen impfstoff wo wir
immer noch wechselnde empfehlungen haben
und auch noch nicht genau die
schutzdauer und wirkung vorhersehen
können für so einen impfstoff können wir
einfach keine impfpflicht aussprechen
auch nicht für besondere berufsgruppen
beispielsweise wie frankreich ist macht
beispielsweise auch wie der ethikrat ja
die empfehlung ausgesprochen hat das
pflegepersonal
verpflichten zu einer impfung aber ist
ja der ist ja das gleiche argument also
ist natürlich man muss appellieren dass
man sich impfen lässt aber stehen wir
mal vor uns vor vor acht monaten hätten
wir eine impfpflicht für pflegeberufe
gehabt mit astra zenica und
heute wissen wir aber dass der asta
zenica bei frauen ab einem bestimmten
alter nicht geben dürfen daher mit so
einer revision immer in der in den
empfehlungen der stiko da kann man im
moment eigentlich keine impfpflicht
aussprechen das ist in ihrer
einschätzung verzeihung pflicht nur die
zuschauern fragte ja auch ob mit einer
impfpflicht ihrer auffassung nach die
pandemie vorbei wäre also hätten wir
wenn es die impfpflicht gäbe und
umgesetzt werden könnte hätten wir dann
heute kein corona mehr also in einer
theoretischen welt wo wir alle geimpft
hätten in deutschland da deren wir in
einer sehr viel entspannteren lage und
wir würden eher von einer pandemie in
einer ende übergehen aber wir hätten
immer noch höhere fallzahlen weil wir ja
auch bei geimpften immer mal wieder
infektionen sehen also der winter wer in
jedem fall entspannter und wir würden
auch schneller durch diese pandemie
kommt das stimmt ja vielleicht wird das
ja als anreiz verstanden wir an all die
15 millionen sind derzeit in deutschland
die einen fix bekommen könnten und sich
derzeit aber noch dagegen entschieden
haben wir schon weiter elke kann sich
nicht erklären woher kommen jetzt
eigentlich diese hohen zahlen im
vergleich zum letzten jahr und in ihre
frage wenn wir einmal reinschauen
hallo mein name ist selber was mich
interessieren würde es wohl kommen
dieses jahr die hohen infektionen zahlen
her die haben die stadt doppelt und wir
sind jetzt erst im november im
verhältnis zum letzten jahr waren dabei
noch nicht mal 20.000
ja also auf der einen seite haben wir
natürlich erst mal die saisonalität
deswegen die fallzahlen natürlich auch
deutlich ansteigen zusätzlich haben wir
viele dieser kontakt beschränkungen die
beim letzten jahr hatten einfach im
moment gar nicht mehr die mobilität hat
deutlich zugenommen wir sehen uns wieder
wir umarmen uns wir feiern deswegen
sehen wir auch erhöhte fallzahlen
zusätzlich kommt auch noch dass wir
nicht mehr richtig testen wir haben
kontakt nach verfolgung in dem sinne
aufgegeben dass wir gar nicht mehr will
wer im moment infiziertes und werden
nicht vor allem symptomatische menschen
werden getestet so dass man mit einer
ganz großen dunkelziffer im moment
rechnen muss also viel höher auch als im
letzten jahr und das erklärt
wahrscheinlich auch warum wir diesen
unterschied sehen also unser verhalten
und auf der anderen seite dass wir das
dunkelfeld überhaupt nicht ausgeleuchtet
haben und das kann dann offenbar auch
die impfung nicht abfedern diesen effekt
ja ich glaube die macht es im moment
schon und das ist ja das bisschen
besorgniserregende dass wir trotz
impfungen solche fallzahlen haben und
wir haben einen effekt durch die impfung
die das infektionsgeschehen herunter
bringt und vor allem auch die
intensivstation im moment noch ein wenig
entlastet die problematik ist aber
hätten wir so einen infektions seinen
letzten herbst und winter gehabt dann
werden unsere kommen wer unser
gesundheitssystem kollabiert also man
sieht diesen deutlichen unterschied wir
haben 50.000 fälle und in den
intensivstationen ist es zwar kritisch
aber wären 50.000 im letzten jahr
gewesen dann wäre das ganze hätte es
ganz anders ausgesehen doch jetzt
schraubt die regierung an den nächsten
maßnahmen zweig plus ist jetzt das
stichwort das hat der
bundesgesundheitsminister heute
angekündigt und auf weitere maßnahmen
noch härtere corona regeln wieder zielt
auch diese zuschauerfrage
wir hatten letztes jahr lockdown kommen
wir dieses jahr ohne lockt dann durch
den winter
also ich finde im lockdown generell kann
man einfach nicht ausschließen auch wenn
es wir alles tun müssen um einen lock
down zu vermeiden was wir brauchen im
moment sind eskalationsstufen wo wir
sagen
dass bei bestimmten bewegungen zum
beispiel in den krankenhäusern bestimmte
schwellenwerte überschritten werden dass
wir dann härtere maßnahmen einführen die
erste stufe könnte zum beispiel einen 3g
plus also genießen und pcr getestet die
nächste stufe vor allem für
großveranstaltungen könnte sein zweig wo
man dann bei den großveranstaltungen
eben nicht mehr darauf setzt dass das
wir zu viele ungeimpfte drin haben die
dann auch die intensivstation belegen
und die folgende
eskalationsstufe zu sagen zwei geht plus
also dass man vorher noch mal alle
antigen testet die geimpft und genießen
das hatte ja der gesundheitsminister
sparen vorgeschlagen weiter wären es
dann kontakt beschränkungen oder dann
absage von großveranstaltungen
ich denke nicht aber das was man wenn
man darüber großveranstaltung redet dass
das generell eine regel sein sollte für
alle öffentlichen bereiche also dass man
sagt dass restaurants nur noch 2 g plus
sind oder dass das einkaufen nur noch
mit zwei gibt los geht also da müssen
wir glaube ich unterscheidungen machen
vor allem die bereiche wo viele menschen
zusammenkommen da müssten wir
restriktiver sein wenn sie die bilder
aus köln sehen wir sind jetzt der elfter
elfter das geht ihnen durch den kopf ja
meine sorge war gar nicht die feier
draußen da wissen wir von der oso
forschung auf farmen verhalten des ewz
dass wir da nicht unbedingt großen
ausbrüche kriegen meine sorge war er und
das kann ich nicht von solchen bildern
einschätzen was in den innenräumen in
privaten feiern passiert ich kann mir
gut vorstellen dass das große karnevals
feiern gegeben hat wo gelacht gesungen
geschunkelt wurde und auf sowas blick
ich im moment ein bisschen mit sorge
weil wir dadurch natürlich ausbrüche
generieren die wir im moment gerade
nicht mehr vertragen sollte man sich
auch geimpfte bei so einer veranstaltung
zweig veranstaltungen in den armen
liegen oder empfehlen sie mittlerweile
nicht mehr dass ich glaube das wichtige
ist dass wir uns allen bewusst sind dass
wir noch mitten in der pandemie sind das
in einer kritischen lage sind das ist
auch schwer einzuschätzen dass wir hoch
die fallzahlen gehen werden keiner kann
das vorhersagen wann wir da
einen schwellenwert erreicht haben wo es
einfach nicht mehr höher geht wir wissen
auch nicht wie viele menschen jetzt auf
der intensivstation aufgrund dieser fall
zahlen die wir heute haben ein paar
tagen landen werden das sind alles
aufgrund der impfung die hilft aber
schwer vorhersehbar und daher würde ich
jedem empfehlen erstmal einmal mehr
abstand zu nehmen er mal die maske zu
tragen er sich mal testen zu lassen oder
er auch mal zu hause zu bleiben wenn sie
sich sorge haben zu infizieren als dass
man das risiko eingeht dazu eine weitere
frage unserer bild zuschauer
hallo herr strikt ich hätte meine frage
und zwar
habe ich jetzt von einzelnen
weihnachtsmärkten gehört die nicht
stattfinden leider und mir leuchtet
nicht ganz ein weil die sind ja
eigentlich an der frischen luft
inwiefern ist so ein weihnachtsmarkt
doch dann problem ja da gebe ich
vollkommen recht also an einen
außenbereichen haben wir eigentlich
nicht so die sorge dass hat er die
großen übertragung haben im gegenteil
ich würde mir wünschen dass die leute
sich draußen treffen da wo die wo man
vielleicht auch mal ein bisschen abstand
erhalten kann wo die übertragung sehr
viel unwahrscheinlicher ist als in den
innenraum und daher
verstehe ich nicht warum man
weihnachtsmärkte absagen kann man kann
natürlich nicht jedes risiko reduzieren
jede übertragung vermeiden das geht
nicht aber in auf weihnachtsmärkte haben
wir nicht das große problem wie wenn wir
das jetzt meine beim club zum beispiel
hätten ihre prognose weihnachten so wie
wir uns das wünschen in diesem jahr ja
es wird nochmal ein komplizierter herbst
und winter das merken wir alle und ist
es auch unheimlich schwierig eine
prognose abzugeben wie sich das weiter
entwickelt also wie gesagt es kann 40
sein dass die welle abflacht das ist
zwar wir weiteren anstieg haben aber
dass es abflacht es kann sein dass es
noch sehr viel weiter hoch ansteuerte in
dem fall sein das kann man im moment
sehr schwer
vorhersagen ich glaube ist es wichtig
dass wir darüber reden und das passt da
vielleicht ist bin ich stimme ich mit
herrn bieler darüber ein dass wir ein
bisschen spät jetzt darüber reden was
eigentlich unsere eskalationsstufen sind
und dann was wir das fest machen können
weil die inzidenz haben wir nicht gut
bestimmt und wissen gar nicht wie viele
infektionen es gibt und auch bei den
krankenhaus belegungen oder
intensivmedizinisch billigen wissen wir
auch nicht genau wo hier eigentlich
unsere schwellen grenzen sind und dass
nach zwei jahren pandemie mittlerweile
wissen sie eigentlich wer die korona
politik die korona regeln in deutschland
aktuell aufstellt wer macht das gerade
ich glaube dass das passiert natürlich
in der politik wahrscheinlich in vielen
hintergrundgesprächen das ist natürlich
eine schwierige situation weil wir eine
amtierende regierung im moment noch
haben die für diese regeln im moment
verantwortlich ist das ist ja nicht das
sind ja nicht die koalitionäre oder dass
es zumindest immer noch über die
epidemische lage nationaler tragweite
bis zum 24 gedeckt daher würden dort
auch die entscheidung getroffen alles
andere wird dann wieder über die
parlamente entschieden werden müssen
aber da wir in diesem übergang sind ist
es natürlich schwierig da auch eine gute
entscheidung zu treffen wenn olaf scholz
zeigt wie vorgestern wir müssen jetzt
deutschland winterfest machen ist das
eine aussage die aus ihrer sicht nicht
ein bisschen spät kommt müssten wir
nicht schon längst winterfest sein zu
diesem zeitpunkt ja mit dem expertenrat
nrw haben wir ja dafür geworben dass wir
ein winterreifen und einen sommerreifen
modus haben im sommer wussten wir dass
wir niedrige fallzahlen haben werden
dass wir damit auch gut umgehen können
da hätte man die maske auch mehr
weglassen können in meinen augen im
winter müssen wir natürlich bevölkerung
wieder darauf vorbereiten dass es da
anders aussieht dass wir wieder
steigende infektionszahlen haben werden
also diesen unterschied den hätte man
von anfang an auch kommunizieren können
dass wir eben einen sommerreifen und
einem winterreifen modus brauchen micron
merken wir seit mittlerweile eigentlich
zwei jahren es gibt kein thema das die
deutschen mehr beschäftigt weil es ihren
alltag ebenso sehr bestimmt und
gleichzeitig gibt es kein thema was die
deutschen so nervt bitte mal was anderes
sind sie selbst genervt von corona
obwohl das ja großer teil ihres jobs ist
also
da muss sich unterscheiden fachlich bin
ich nicht genervt von corona also da
gibt es unheimlich viele spannende
fragen und auch publikationen an dem man
arbeitet und dann bin ich überhaupt
nicht genervt natürlich einige fragen
wie man gar nicht beantworten kann wie
geht es weiter in den prognosen wie wird
der herbst wie wird der winter die wird
weihnachten das kann man ja gar nicht
vorhersagen und das sind dann fragen die
dann irgendwann auch schwierig wenn sie
das denn privat als geologe gehen sie
jetzt noch zu einem abendessen für zehn
oder zwanzig menschen sind würden sie
auf eine kleine party gehen wo ist ihre
ganz persönliche grenze
unterschiedlich das kann ich nicht so
pauschal beantworten was wir häufig
machen das ist aber auch im gerade im
krankenhaus eine besondere
sorgfaltspflicht dass wir hier sind ja
alle geimpft in unserem institut
ausnahmslos aber wenn wir dann in privat
treffen gehen also wie ich das dann
halte das mich häufig vorher noch mal
testen um einfach das
infektionsgeschehen niedrig zu halten
ich finde es richtig dass wir jetzt
kostenlose tests wieder anbieten können
weil dadurch können wir einfach den
menschen auch mehr eigenverantwortung
geben dass sie selber sich einmal mehr
testen als zu wenig letzte frage welche
bereifung tragen wir denn gerade draußen
ist es nasskalt sind es noch
sommerreifen auf dem wir fahren oder
haben wir da wenigstens allwetter schon
ja ich glaube das auto wird gerade in
die garage gefahren gut das klingt es
dauert es noch ein bisschen dass sich
nach lockdown
gegeneinander aber es geht ja genau um
das dass wir im eskalationsstufen
entwerfen das ja auch gucken für welches
wetter brauchen wir die richtigen reifen
euch das war doch mal schneller und
agiler sind dass wir mal an dem einen
tag die reifen aufziehen und auf den man
machen die anderen reifen und dass ihr
aber trotzdem deutlich machen dass wir
hier eine angespannte situation
reinfahren und deswegen vorsicht geboten
ist das war die korona sprechstunde
hierbei spielt live danke an den job
virologen professor hendrik strikt
hierbei bild live sie durften fragen und
er hatte wie ich finde sehr klare
antworten darauf